hello and welcome to lobby gamespot's
weekly hang out every tuesday at two
p.m. pacific right here on gamespot com
for sports want to say notorious conor
mcgregor to swear I Maddy throne shirt
here did you guys enjoy the fight on the
weekend enjoy that image you sent me
that made me very happy i didn't watch
this Robbie Lawler's face like opened up
did he talk the whole time he did they
interviewed him with his mouth open you
have seen man you think video games or
violent what caused that much to watch
that he got a cake or a punch or
something elbow probably right boom that
was the skulls of the shogun shirt get
my works for both yeah probably how the
audience thought that as well ha windows
phone game yeah clusen but we're not
here to talk about skulls of the shogun
we're here to talk about my witcher 3
wild hunt ty route andy baman yes we've
all been playing a bunch of the witcher
3 y level are you 25 what Larry 70 just
kidding right this is a watch I
downloaded a saved game that has a level
70 or did you yes got my name Sean
HIGHlarious it also has 15 billion
crowns just decapitating people once way
I'm really nice loot chest right yeah
alien it was a Witcher 3 mod but the
point is we've all played the hell out
of that game and if you're like the
summertime is even like it's perfectly
set up for this because then we can keep
playing it but like the sort of black of
games that's going on and you're like a
bunch against me I haven't even finished
the freaking story I mean I feel like
I've gotten way more out of it than any
we were talking to Chris earlier he's
level 22 and he hasn't gone through the
skeller yeah I spent an hour yesterday
trying to beat a fellow Witcher on a
horseback race because gotta get that
sad look us [ __ ] roads for some
reason when he gets to a bridge freaks
out and then cross it like he just stops
yeah which is being fixed soon but yes
so they have been fixing they've been
patching the game and they've been
adding a bunch of DLC the software got
talked to that in a second but the big
patch that's come out is basically the
one that's allowed you to change up your
inventory and it's got a back comes out
well later we actually know when it
comes up but I can't tell you oh really
apparently soon very soon okay yeah so
that's good like a bunch of fixes which
is kind of like traditional for CD
Projekt games to release the oh okay
that everything works now patch but
they've also been adding a bunch of free
DLC and he talked to me about this you
did a bunch of videos on games Bob
basically like
talking about each piece of DLC that
they're releasing like right over a
dozen pieces of DLC 16 right yes in
total so a lot of them are just armor
and costume looks for the ancillary
characters like Anna fur and tris and
this week's is this is your cereal for
Cirie and and then one of them was gwent
pack what ya know you guys are integrate
I'm not even going when that's another
layer on top of my images who don't have
the energy to like dive into I just boot
up to which you had to get to Gwen yeah
I want it to be separate Erica on steam
that's pretty good what our stuff they
got anyway well um yeah they have L
crossbow yeah they take rest elite
inquest and nobody yet so saving that
for less because that's what I was
waiting I was like yeah it's do some new
quest because these are the best things
about this game or the size of us right
so there's like what four or five before
quests and I've played them all they're
all really good they're all short but
sweet and yeah I think it just goes to
show that CD Projekt is super like good
at using their tools to make there's one
out with the high ten right oh yeah is
that yeah I can just like do the
dialogue do the animation do the city
see the cinematic shots of the the when
you're talking even like program pigs to
be in it and like talk to you spoiler
and then it's like yeah they get the
there's a book a yeah they draw a lot of
references to the books in the in the
dlc quest because like hey why not like
this is there time for their super fans
to actually like digging harder and
stuff yeah for shin and they're the ones
they're probably seek out these quests
like like me so it's like yeah they're
they're just awesome to play through but
like third you know pretty quick quick
the news and just armor and coils like
it's like some work though so saying
like 16 deals to you yeah this is like
it's a little bit of a PR like in their
column for sure they get a win because
presumably than the roads that wants us
to purchase yeah I which will happen but
I mean it is super cool like compared to
other games that would charge you for
all this yeah like nickel and dime you
or what other games that would pull back
so much content the edge like my problem
with SME being that
not that much in the game so that's why
everyone's buying all the dlc right like
they're giving you free DLC in this game
but you don't need it is already talked
about 10 cheap tactics here you know
like it's not like like we just we were
discussing dragon age origins we're like
yeah like a free piece of DLC with the
game and then you go to like your camp
and there's some guy going hey by the
way you should buy this piece of
Achilles you want to hear about a story
of yeah a mean like I've does but not
are you breaking the immersion but
you're trying to [ __ ] me over yeah so
this is not like that at all I think
this is more meaty stuff even the psych
West I think our media I mean they they
release the wolf gear like those
scavenger hunts are probably my favorite
part of that game I mean I spent so many
hours trying to hunt for like feline
armor ursuline armor and now i'm doing
the warmer yeah and like I spent so much
time last night just trying to get that
stuff and it does last a long time
because you have to be certain levels
and then you can go all the way up to
level 34 stuff and like it's like
mastercraft gear so I mean I I think
there's some meaty content there there's
also some stuff I don't want to talk
about the graduation spoiler right it's
amazing SciQuest they're like the
skeletons most wanted and i think is
what's called yeah that's a really cool
awesome one it's such a great side quest
it has relevance the entire game i I
once you get to that level i encourage a
lot people play about excellent so
that's that's all the stuff that I've is
sort of like handing a piecemeal over
the past couple of weeks yes I devil's
eye patch the game which is great for
people especially with the in terms of
the controller fixes I feel like a lot
of people been asking for and the a
notorious but yeah that's gonna be great
the book is gonna love a book on top of
my god later on this year we have actual
paid dlc coming yet and that also sounds
like it's pretty expensive alright so
according to g 0 g on October
thirty-first they're gonna release the
thing called hearts of stone when it
must be a little reference there but a
10 hour adventure that takes place in no
man's land right ok so they're just
building more quests in an existing land
have they said whether that's going to
be post campaign ah yes you can play the
game after the choice better it's
probably it probably is irrelevant to
like just fits right in yeah just just
like get a contract and it goes crazy
probably probably I don't know and
that's the smaller of two expansion
packs that they've done talking about
the big one for twenty bucks I think
well I don't know what they are
individually I think you can buy a pass
for 24 I know you can buy a pass for
twenty-five dollars they're nice
999 be good both 2525 it's actually is
pretty reasonable 30 hours of content
yeah yeah good yes so the second we're
ragging on destiny too much yeah but
those ones cost more than $25 that's
true yeah uh no no Donna so I'm gonna do
destiny defenders back yeah oh yeah the
second one which comes out in q1 slated
they don't know for sure is gonna be
called blood and wine 20-hour thing with
a brand new area that's pretty cool new
area called Toussaint or something right
do you rember it off in the books if I
did I don't know yeah I got too much too
much like what's your stuff man there
was weird words my keeping Irish words
thrown in there to the context that are
like why did he say tersh acht that's
weird that's not how you say crack on
crotch yeah so I like going on so much
man it just reminds because I feel like
I'm just talking to your people the
entire yeah it's great Scotty Garland's
man they're just owned by a bunch of
people from Belfast yeah and yes all
that stuff's coming out late next year
so imma be playing even more richer what
does this like make you feel about when
when you're because there's been so many
games that come as you know it's not
just the game that I keep mentioning but
like games like evolved for instance
yeah like right up front they were
talking about here's our strategy this
weekend the Batman you sell skins yeah
right she's the best you get a few skins
like I mean it's the Sanskrit oh it's no
secret like a lot of gamers feel burned
by mean the fact is like you have a lot
of games to pass we just mentioned
dragon age origins you had like things
like mass effect where you know Mass
Effect 3 there's like this like from
ashes DLC that you can buy for 10 bucks
yeah like it involves a very important
character that's in a big integral part
right Doria like why is this not free
and then you have things like you have
companies like Capcom who like include
the DLC in the disk yeah but lock it
behind the paywall essentially you know
so it's I think I mean obviously I think
people are learning from their mistakes
now I like about CD Projekt RED is like
they're clearly passionate about their
audience and what their fans want and I
think it's great to see that content
with that push for content whether it's
free DLC like the 16 pieces that we're
getting now and in the expansion packs
that are actually you can call the media
expansion pack yeah I don't like two to
three hours of experience that's more
like you know you get 30 you know and
that's it's good bang for your buck and
I mean you know despite the fact i still
believe games are cheaper now than they
ever have
yeah sure especially when you account
for inflation I still think that you're
getting a lot of value here and then
they clearly care they're there they're
gamers too so they get it so going
forward do you think that like sets a
different president now because we kind
of for a while it looked like we'd
gotten used to getting nickel and dimed
post-release you think a game like The
Witcher because it's like had this sort
of widespread success it's sold really
well it's been on like consoles and PC
and been critically lauded and also
liked loved by gamers do you think
because this is the game that's done
this that like that it's almost like
setback that sort of push into
nickel-and-diming gamers that we've seen
happen for the past you know couple of
years I don't know because CD Projekt
they were they've been super smart and
kind of like SAT back and watched what's
happened to the industry before they
like had a plan for this game and
they're operating and like such a big
scale now compared to what they were
before so they can like have a group of
designers make armor and kind of like
have that costs built in to the four
million units are the one price only
pre-orders yeah like they have all this
plans outright and plus they're they're
probably operating at it like a little
less of a cost then say like your EA or
something cuz it goes Hollen Albright
ABI goes further the dollar goes further
there so yeah it's hard to say because
they're private too so it's like they
can do what I really want they can just
look as good as they want to look and
gamers will appreciate that then
everybody benefits and not beholding to
some shareholders or acquiring which was
later due to be to be honest like that
shouldn't they're like the CD Projekt
way would actually benefit probably
every company right like it would be
better for shareholders if other
companies did this you and I don't think
yeah i just don't think they have that
much they're not looking far enough
ahead they're looking at like the
quarter so they're like let's sell this
right now in the court of thing and see
projects like let's like build trust
with our gamers yeah and so they're
gonna buy five million copies of
freaking cyberpunk because they know
what well i guess if you're releasing a
game every you know three to four to
five years probably want to make sure
you're you've got people who are going
to support you and you release your next
game ago and that's the thing I mean you
look at games now there are plenty of
games are short right we're talking like
four to six hours and there with no
replayability value whatsoever there are
sixty dollars so yeah yes I'm like a
wizard 60 bucks it's like a
under plus our experience not to mention
you have all that free DLC you were
winning the the favor of your audience
at that point and the trust and at some
point they're going to look in bike okay
there's an expansion pack I played 16
are I played a bunch of SciQuest they
release for free they were actually good
i can only imagine what the expansion
packs will be now yeah they probably
have a pretty good percentage on the
amount of people that'll pick up their
post release expansion pack I guess
we'll have to find out ty naughty thank
you so much coming on talking about
Gareth with me we'll be back in just a
couple of minutes we got we're gonna
talk about five nights at Freddy's real
hard turn there and after this well
we'll be back in just a second with a
split-screen teaser for gun scape it's
like a landscape but guns
five nights at Freddy's there's already
four of them well no it's already three
of them there's nearly four of them soon
there might be five what's going on at
Freddy's what's this is a game that came
airs August of last year initially at
you played the first one Johnson Mary
you've put him in prolific you played
the second of Thrones on a bunch of live
streams here at gamespot and they're
gearing up for a fourth game which is
going to be released on the anniversary
of the first game what the hell is going
on with the series Mary yeah it's it's
amazing that you can crank out four
games in one year and it's all basically
one guy Scott Lawson who like has
created this but it is he making the
same game every year or every couple of
months because from the outside looking
in it looks like it's the same like
basic mechanics for each one of these
explain what a find that to Freddie's
game is to like folks who might not know
right i mean this is this grew out of
such a simple concept which is that
you're a security guard and you're
checking all these cameras and you're
stopping these animatronics from
basically trying to shove you in their
suit which is filled with gears that
would essentially kill you but he he had
Scott did change up the game
significantly for each time so in the
first one you're this guard you get you
know there's about four main ones that
come and get you there's a chica who
typically comes oh that's Bonnie the
bunny she typically comes from the West
chica comes from the east and then you
have foxy that piece of [ __ ] I hate him
the most and then there's golden bear
himself Freddy and you know and then
they mix it up in the second one there's
a lot more options there's like a
balloon boy and they start coming
through the ventilation systems so just
cross this is me and alexa playing it
later so you'd think that you'd change
that now you can put a mask on and
protect yourself but oh there's a
musical box that you have to complete
you have to consistently keep playing
and then in the third one then you
become a part of atra the attraction so
you're no longer a security guard at the
place
you are a part of an attraction at like
an amusement park and people are just
watching you freak out right so he is
going which is really fascinating
because the game itself no is it that
interesting not really but what makes it
interesting is maybe the lore and the
story is that these characters are
telling so in the first one there's a
lot of hints that you're actually
children died there was like a shootout
and like children died there and so
their spirits are basically inhabiting
these animatronics and then that's
what's killing people so that's what's
so fascinating and now they're like
starting to kind of really hone in on
that well then that's the lore that
makes this game so interesting to people
I don't really actually think it's the
mechanics it's it's it's just before the
gameplay yeah it's it has this cult
following it's that people delvin even
from the very first game is that they
kept diving into the stories like what
does this all mean and that it we keep
writing about it it keeps popping up in
the news because people are finding new
things in like new connections between
the games and that itself like that
thing that they've created around it is
actually kind of exciting is this just
basically the 21st century of you know
version of us like saying Bloody Mary
Bloody Mary to into mirrors because it's
like this whole like creepypasta
Slenderman era of games or like
especially like internet myths which
kind of propagate especially with young
audiences so you tend to like these
games whenever you like look up like
twitch streams or like youtubers playing
them it's always seems to be targeted at
that's sort of like young gamer who
might not necessarily be actually be
buying this game with just it's got this
massive following around people playing
it that's that's such a fascinating
concept Danny it's like not that the
game itself is so terrifying but what
could be the recesses of your
imagination is really what the most
scary thing is about this series and you
could see that even like I don't know
like 10 years ago when the blair witch
project came out right what people the
movie was not scary but what was scary
about it was the concept that this might
exist right and so there was all this
lore on the internet about what actually
happened and did these people really die
and and there was always oh this was
based on a true story of all these
people died and so this is what kind of
happened with Freddie that people
started thinking that this was based off
of true stories of people actually dying
and and and because of our electronic
affairs
I mean it's carrying a 70 yeah but like
that's what's interesting I think that's
what it appeals to so many people and so
he's kind of like stepped it up a notch
in this fourth one you're going to see a
lot of from what you can see in the
trailer there's a lot that you can
gather it's being in a house now that's
really fascinating and so your home and
they're here in your home why would you
have animatronic things in your home
that's a really good question nanny so
there's two possibilities one would be
that this guy took them home after
Freddy's burnt down to the ground he he
like collected them and brought them
home maybe you like you know any1
animatronic am yeah nothing's better
than having animatronic animals and you
have to this was something that you were
learning about and now you've gone
insane oh okay in your imagination and
this is something that you're just
concocted in your brain and it could
actually make you I don't have a heart
attack or die so you are now the kid
watching the YouTube streams who's now
gone crazy and thinks that maybe
something like that it's possible I
think that's you know what so this is a
like these mini Freddy minions that are
on your bed that's behind use this is
like different so instead of cameras
there's been no cameras officially that
I can tell yet but there's a right door
and a left or in which they pay homage
to the original Freddy because chica and
Bonnie make a return and they're from
the same direction so again cheetah
you've got such depth of knowledge and
all this sort of stuff this is what's so
fascinating about those that people who
like paid attention to these things
might have to write because there's
nothing really else going on I got what
I think one of my favorite things i like
is that the trailers are clearly just
made by somebody unlike vegas something
only looks like so budget but so why do
you think about like a game they're
worth that like nothing on saying they
cost nothing it's like with 75 bucks
like you can basically get like three of
them I think for something like twenty
dollars all three of them and a hack
like it just do you think it's okay to
release four games of the same like even
if you created a genre on your own
basically is it still okay to release
four games within you know 12 months of
each other of course I and part of it is
it's like the DLC that we're getting
with something like The Witcher like
that you're not just your getting the
main game and you get a you get
something to experience and then you get
a map pack of you
or a month later and then another map
pack a month after that and kind of
interestingly kind of as a side note the
game was supposed to come out but the
next freddie was sposed to come out on
halloween he's pushed it up to the
anniversary of the first game and
there's going to be a free update to the
game coming at Halloween cool and for me
I like I think that's a really smart way
for for an indie dev like this who's
who's created something that has really
caught on with people to keep getting
that attention and it will and keep
getting money to like keep getting paid
to make this game and if people are
still interested in and they want new
levels like well why not pay for kind of
what this is which is a substantial
update instead of like saying I'm gonna
make the entire game like what if he had
spent the past couple years making all
of these into one huge game like rice he
wouldn't have messaged necessarily have
even had the money to do that but this
has let him create something that's kind
of small at the beginning and like oh
this has a has a following people like
this let me make the next big set of
levels for it and just keep going in
that way I don't think he had any idea
it just would blow up the way it had I
think this was a surprise and you can
definitely see the budget in the trailer
I think he still has these humble
beginnings like there's this part in the
end for the logo kicks in and the
background is red and then just like yes
like it's obvious like who paid you to
do that like you know he just did that
and Alika sitting on the afternoon on a
track pad like awkwardly throwing it
together but no one gives a [ __ ] and no
you know what nobody even cares that you
the graphics aren't incredibly amazing
the animations are going to clean yeah
well I heard that the original idea of
the animatronics is because he created a
game previously and people criticized it
because I everyone looked like they were
animatronic they look too scary he um
he's a lot of Christian games actually
so he was like really a hard swing it is
isn't an eye and he said he doesn't like
have any regrets about it or anything
that was just something that he dabbled
in but because those animatronics were
so scary he said like one night he was
just like wow yeah what if I scared the
[ __ ] out of people and your weakness
into a strike that's right I mean it's
like a little cinderella story but with
like scary murder there you go five
nights at Freddy's it's set on iOS as
well and there apparently is some sort
of movie in the works I've heard who
knows the internet that could all just
be nonsense as well maybe very well it's
true and last question for both you guys
do you think this is something we could
see on next-gen console Justin yeah I
don't see why not like
part of it is just he needs to maybe
reach out to Microsoft or Sony or and
get them to reach out to him like this
seems like it would be in some ways a
really good fit for a console hmm it
would be something fun it would
definitely expand the audience may be a
catch game with really these games a two
player no but I mean a lot of times
you'd play them with friends but it's a
single operated game because everybody
can be scared when something comes up on
screen inside yeah yeah yeah and you
mean imagine the possibilities of five
nights at Freddy's with oculus and
actually learning behind you in soon all
right it's totally possible yeah I rap
for Morpheus five nights at Freddy's my
killer Cummings all good murder you
actually yeah I'm Morpheus version of
five guys Freddy's that sounds all right
all right five nights at Freddy's it's
out later this next month august eighth
and on the pc love is the fourth game in
the series and now you can check out the
other three on steam right now i will be
back in a second speaking of any games
gilded dungeoneering a game we played at
right here actually during our st.
Patty's Day it was a piss-up let's just
call it a piss up a stream should be
ready can oh yeah we should lead us
maybe Patty's Day wait you guys have any
when are we should have done from july
4th what's the next big drinking like
festival friday every friday thirsty
thursday or thursdays yeah Christmas
Thanksgiving know Thanksgiving is a bit
oh yeah Oh anytime there's family
involved there's drinking yes yes Amy oh
yeah it's not an Irish thing it's a
family thing sis anyone was family
drinks on there around speaking of
drinking I don't know Gilda
dungeoneering is out and in a couple of
days I believe and here's a trailer for
it it's pretty good game checking it
okay
that became the about the jute wedge on
tania's will be killed but you want to
carry cheers here I'm
dungeoneering deliciously
try to fight the fight what's not in
your time
turn away see how they run away you
Oh
just again show on the road
we want to be agitating earlier this
week the games industry was shocked to
hear of the tragic early passing of
Nintendo CEO cetera whatta on sunday
evening was when the new sort of came
through that he had sadly died of a
problem with a bile duct cancer i
believe on saturday night nintendo put
out an announcement and the world of
video games sort of wheeled back and
thought about the impact that this one
individual had on an hour and our
beloved hobby Justin the news breaking
on Sunday where were you and you when
you heard it oh I was on my way back
from comic-con like I was literally in
the cab in one of our news guys Eddie
makuu texted me he was like satori wada
just passed away mm-hmm um and I was I
like I'd have no idea what I'm what I
should do like cuz I'm on the cab on the
way to go like in and of course like we
don't want to take advantage of
something like that it's such a huge
thing like you want to make sure that we
are honoring that memory and the right
way but also letting our audience know
like this is a huge important thing that
that just happened and and of course on
gamespot there was a lot of content that
we put around it because he has made
such a huge impact despite being someone
who are probably in recent years has
seen more corporate he spent the
president Nintendo he's had a huge
impact in development of games and in
the shape of Nintendo for such a long
time that's like what are the ways that
we can honor that like we're not a
traditional news organization we don't
just have all these obituaries would
written although maybe we should start
doing that but and then he was taken so
suddenly that here was a young guy 55
years is not old we knew that obviously
he was on well last year 83 he had a
limited participation and this year of
course they did the sort of motif with
their Nintendo Direct of having him and
Reggie and everyone as puppets was there
ever any sort of concern on your guys
was there any like and I never dawned on
me at the moment but presumably he's
actually been still sick this whole time
the last Nintendo Direct he looked much
thinner like it was noticeably thinner
and then when you had this sense into
directing that they didn't appear at all
it wasn't like a transition into puppets
it was literally a puppet e at the other
time like
that definitely made us a little bit
more concern but he's at the same time
he's such a young person like someone
who can overcome something like that
that it was still quite a surprise let's
step away from the sort of tragic event
and and maybe frame this or Center on
this on on the wonderful work he did
during his his life and his time at
Nintendo and he started off and I was he
working at Hal or did he work on some
games before he was at out he started
working on some games on his own he
famously picked up an HP calculator and
started programming games and that kind
of got him into it at a time when being
a game developer wasn't a respected
position especially in Japan it was
something you wouldn't admit and he
started working in Akihabara which is
the sort of nerds epicenter of Tokyo
making games with his friends and
working at how he then ended up helping
Nintendo fix one of their games and
pinball and from there they had a really
good working relationship how actually
went under some financial issues and
Hiroshi Yamauchi who is the last member
of the founding family of Nintendo to be
the president of the company brought him
in brought Hal in because they had such
a good relationship and in 2002 you
malchi pointed satori wada as president
of Nintendo because he shared the same
lateral thinking when it came to
utilizing technology the sort of thought
that we always had to chase the bleeding
edge of tech is a losing battle to these
guys because there's always going to be
something better so they thought okay
how can we take technology that exists
and utilize that in an interesting way
and that was sort of how you know that
was the game boy that was the same thing
that uh gunpei yokoi via metro the game
boy game boy used to create that and
this was a lot of thinking when it came
to designing something like the wii mmm
he used existing harder from the
gamecube but it it tweaked it in a
different way and and that sort of
thinking is something that you wanna you
know carried with him but he was also
someone who is very passionate about the
creation of games not just the business
of games and who famously would help you
know he'd be walking around the floor
and watch people make games and say
numbers a problem with that and sit down
and start program like the president of
the company walking behind you takes
your chair and does your job for you but
that's that's because he cares and he's
knowledgeable and you know he knows what
he wants
an interesting anecdote he was on
gamecenter CX which is this Japanese
program recently I needed an interview
with the guys and it's it's kind of a
fun program where they play video games
and he was talking about how his father
did not condone him playing like being a
video game designer like it's not a job
and he was like the interview was saying
well didn't that make you want to turn
away that you want to you know Japan
very respectful of your family
especially from his generation and he
was like no this is what I was
passionate about I want to make games
and this is what I cared about and it
paid off obviously that he's brought I
think more legitimacy to games than
anybody else like that's what Nintendo
has done for us that as much as we think
of them as a kid system it's more that
they're friendly like they're in
everybody system and he's one of the
driving forces behind that yeah and he
came in obviously I would think was the
Gamecube all already sort of on the on
the way out by the time he came in but a
you know part of the teams who develops
and masterminded the wii the DS as well
his later you know two of perhaps the
most mainstream successful you know
consoles both in the house and handheld
of all time his later career involved
the 3ds which obviously had a lot of
problems he famously took a pay cut as
well after the investors call with the
sort of lack of success of the Wii U as
well and it is sort of sad that the last
two things that he was involved in ended
up being and parts of Nintendo that
perhaps didn't strike the iron quite as
hot as we hear that yeah not it looks
like to that about the 3ds the three
years definitely started out slowly but
it's picked up momentum so much it is
still the dominant hand held and it's
hard to reach the peak of what the d/s
was but it's definitely come a long way
did just like it's impossible to compare
yourself to the wii which was it isn't
that transcended console with
transcendent gamers that became like a a
mobile device almost is that the wii u
hasn't lived up to that isn't surprising
is that just the nature of of be having
that mindset of being on the critical
agent trying things different is that
for every we you that you have you have
a wii for every every sort of dangerous
idea that didn't really take off you
have one that completely revolutionizes
in the industry I mean that's the risk
you take whenever you try to innovate
right I mean you really don't know how
things are going to pan out until you
give it a shot and sometimes you know
you strike gold sometimes
fine call yeah but you find calling a
call that's all positive right hit it he
can sell cold yeah sure yeah and i still
love playing my wii u as well I just I
don't know I kind of want to go back to
the fact that he took a pay cut you know
it never been an industry where Studios
tend to shudder when a game was in duel
or even when a game just finishes and
the company gets rid of them we live in
a world where CEOs get shuffled where
they pretend they did a good job move on
to the next company yeah it was there
for four years and it's something that's
particular to Japan but also at Nintendo
where when you become an employee at a
company you're an employee for life in
most cases and when you look at Nintendo
and you look at the people who are there
you know and when you consider you wada
as well there is sort of an old guard
that was protecting everything and and
the fact that that he it seems that he
cherished the company and his people
enough because he had been taken care of
so well that he sought to sort of
payback you know that that loyalty by by
not getting rid of people by doing what
it took to keep the company and his
employees alive is is remarkable and
that just speaks to the sort of person
that that we've lost and I think why it
means so much it's not just that he was
a well-known person is that he was a
well-known person who was respected and
respected his peers yeah what do you
think finally this means for the future
of Nintendo obviously with the NX
presumably will see it in 2016 the
future of Nintendo with their
partnerships in mobile and whatnot and
sort of a that's been a carrot on a
stick for a lot of people a lot of
companies recently in the immediate
direction but we're not going to see any
change the indexed year or the year
after that even like any kind of change
will take years to because the Nintendo
itself has always been a slower moving
company as we've seen but at the same
kit does of course make me worry a
little bit like that awada is someone
who came from the ranks he's like
Miyamoto he's a designer he's a creator
and he was able to speak to that side of
being a president and i hope that
Nintendo continues with that that the
next person who comes into that role is
is equally passionate and equally
creative than I I imagine Nintendo has
to keep up that idea that I wouldn't
think that they would ever bring in
someone who's like and now we're going
to monetize the [ __ ] out of this like
I think both as respect at to his memory
and out of respect to the type of
company that they are and it wasn't
particular to justy wat it wuz that's
what Nintendo was about and he was a an
amazing representation of that and I
think that they'll find somebody who
will continue that same legacy and I
hope they will I think it's going to be
a massive challenge for them to do that
it's you know they've been so lucky over
the years to have people who are so
passionate about the company and about
gaming at large I don't think that's
easy to replicate I don't think that's
easy to put out like a call for a job
like we you need these qualities like
that that's something you prove through
years of dedication and struggle yeah
and I don't know who at Nintendo can do
that I don't think Miyamoto is suitable
for that role at this point in career if
I don't think he wants to know I don't
know some sent ya like it's way too late
for that for him to take over in that
capacity so I don't know who at Nintendo
is well he's really there and we don't
see that many people I think that a good
fit would be someone like me I'm just
gonna throw my head out there if you
want to know the president it's a thing
and we may look back at this in three or
four years five years and think this was
the end of one ERA of Nintendo I guess
we'll have to wait and find out Justin
Peter thank you so much for coming on
and thanks to a water sound as well for
all the wonderful video games and
consoles that we enjoy playing may rest
in peace and we better not finish a show
on such a somber note let's let's look
what we have anything left here in the
running order again for wet got a
giveaway talk about hard turns and we
have a giveaway a pretty tasty when
actually playstation 4 call of duty
black ops 3 zombies mystery box that's
why i looked it up on the laptop and
didn't try and learn it before the show
HTTP colon slash slash wwwdcom forge /
ps4 hyphen call hyphen of hyphen duty
hyphen giveaway forward slash go over
there and you've a chance to win the
call of duty black ops 3 zombies mystery
box Mary what's in the mystery box it's
a mystery apparently what's in the box
are you Kevin Spacey what's in the
box they aren't they showing you what's
in the box right there it's a pretty
friggin good box the only made like a
eight of these I think all the details
there on the page if you want to win and
just get in there and fill in the
details what you say it's a ps4 black
ops 2 a sick box keep going Mary
lithographs anything else it's a box
what's in the box check it out and you
can go to the URL on screen now I'm sure
somebody's spamming it in the chat right
now and I'm sure our diligent folks on
the gamespot Twitter on Facebook pages
will be putting it up there as well if
you want to win yourself a PlayStation 4
in a sweet box and you want to win some
lithographs and maybe a mystery I go
over to that page fill in the details
and cross you goddamn fingers and toes
gentlemen thank you so much for coming
on today what is he off doing this week
on gamespot com you don't know cuz
you're doing the news you know right
every day is a surprise what's gonna
happen I'll you know games jared leto
being Joker who knows I guess Peter
Brackett we're building a
four-hundred-dollar pc we're kind of
revisiting that feature we did last year
where can you build the peace gaming PC
for the price of a console yeah and if
you can how well will they compared to
the consoles now that they both cost
four hundred dollars Tech has gone down
in price a little bit on the pc side
although not much we're putting that to
the test to see how that works out look
for it this weekend if I get my [ __ ]
done excellent and my review of F 1 2015
should hopefully be heading the site but
they are tomorrow and it's going to
create at the moment which usually takes
about two weeks with my reviews about
the rhythm ah those Irish colloquial is
exactly i keep saying shillelagh top of
the morning codemasters and there is a
quick look up on gamespot com from our
partners over a giant bomb if you want
some information on that yeah and we'll
have an episode of the points that this
week as well which will be all about at
the life and work of mystery water until
then we will see you guys next week have
a great weekend placing in 1000 games at
your friends and we will see you next
Tuesday adios
now III so you did a good job good thank
you thank you so we'll see you at dinner
ok see ya saturday yeah
you non specific action figure did the
best job
you
you